pour les juré du Festival de Venise qui
s'est terminé hier la meilleure actrice
est française elle s'appelle pascaleier
elle sait ce que le cinéma veut dire
puisque sa maman n'est autre que la
comédienne buogier mais la fille n'est
pas une inconnue pour autant on l' déjà
vu dans le pont du nord de jacqu Rivette
pourant à Venise elle ne s'attendit pas
à une telle au 'en explique à
Pier
uneprise pr le le Lion d'or pour Eric
Romer pour son film mais c'était
tellement bouleversant pour moi c'est
formidable parlez-nous du personnage
maintenant écoutez Louise c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui véhicule beaucoup
d'émotions dans le film et c'est
quelqu'un qui a peur tout le temps qui
est très volontaire qui aimerait qui
aspire à l'amour unique mais qui
finalement disperse ses sentiments et
c'est un petit peu ça le problème alors
elle est en train une personne avec qui
elle vit un petit peu pe plus âgé
qu'elle un confident amoureux et puis le
désir de sortir et de pas s'intégrer
totalement dans la structure d'un couple
si c'est elle tant mieux mais c'est
manifestement pas le cas alors tant pis
Gry tu l'as pourtant bien vu bah oui à
moins que j'ai une hallucination cela
dit il a parfaitement le droit d'aller à
Paris comme moi j'en ai parfaitement le
droit aussi sans le dire sans le dire et
puis je lui poserai jamais de question
et tu ne sauras jamais et je saurai
jamais quelle importance si lui il a la
délicatesse de pas me demander ce que je
fais quand je suis à Paris et ben moi
c'est
pareil toute façon peut-être à tort ou à
raison je pense que je m'amuse plus que
lui quand je suis là non mais je suis de
plus en plus contente de mon idée de
coucher à Paris maintenant ça va tout à
fait bien entre nous est-ce que c'est
vous est-ce que c'est un personnage de
Romer non c'est un personnage de Romer
Romer écrit ses scripts très précisément
sans idée précise d'un comédien puis
après il y a une deuxième vague où il
écrit en pensant à quelqu'un puis après
on
s'adapte et en dehors du rôle est-ce que
vous avez fait d'autres choses sur le
film j'ai j'ai collaboré avec Romer
pendant plusieurs mois sur la
préparation du film repérage extérieur
intérieur décoration costume et à qui la
récompense de Venise fait-elle le plus
plaisir est-ce que c'est à vous est-ce
que c'est à bulogier votre mère ou
est-ce que c'est à romère écoutez romè
est très content pour moi
personnellement c'est c'est une
récompense formidable parce que ça salue
beaucoup de travail de la part de de
toute l'équipe euh
c'est merveilleux par rapport à Bull
aussi pour moi c'est un cadeau que je
lui offre comme c'est un cadeau qu'elle
m'a fait de m'élever dans une idée du
cinéma et puis c'est un cadeau de romè
aussi parce que c'est lui qui m'a fait
commencer donc c'est assez bouleversant
pour moi de quand la troisème fois je
travaille avec lui tout à coup le la
récompense arrive une autre sorte
d'émotion